john legend joins me now john thanks so
much for coming on the show
mary it's great to see you and it's
great to finally be on your new show
congratulations
appreciate it uh and we are so delighted
to have you
i mean it's been a very difficult few
weeks for you and your family i know our
condolences to you all
and yet here you are in pennsylvania
campaigning on the eve of this election
that's how important this is to you what
is at stake here in this election
for you well i believe our democracy
is at stake we have a choice between uh
joe biden who believes in democracy
believes in the will the people
prevailing
uh has been out here listening to the
people and campaigning honestly to win
their votes
and then you have donald trump who is
actively trying to suppress the vote
actively trying to put up barriers to
voting
and actively trying to send his
lawyers and his minions out there to uh
prevent the counting of votes that he
didn't approve
of and uh that's fascist behavior that's
not the behavior
of someone who wants to lead the world's
greatest democracy so
uh yeah we have a choice now between
um someone who wants to be an
authoritarian
and someone who wants to lead a great
democracy and uh
i think the choice is abundantly clear
and that's why
i had to come out and support joe biden
and kamal harris
so john you are out campaigning with
carmel harris in pennsylvania tonight
now there's nothing new about voter
suppression in this country but there
does seem to be a lot of it around in
2020 with republicans trying
in multiple states including
pennsylvania to try and stop
votes from getting counted how free and
fair an election do you think this
actually is
you know i've seen some reports where um
in fact there's been more expansion of
voting rights during this time
than uh than getting rid of voting
rights
so i think at the same time that one
party
is actively trying to suppress votes i
think turnout is going to be extremely
high
because so many people have decided that
they're determined to vote despite the
fact that
one party is trying to limit their vote
so many
state leaders in blue and purple states
have done what they could to expand
voting access
because because they know that other
people are trying to suppress it so i
think the
the net effect of it will be that we'll
actually have higher turnout
because uh people realize how precious
their vote is
and how determined some forces in this
country are to limit their vote
uh i think you're right about that about
turnout and we'll see tomorrow
um you're in pennsylvania uh whereas you
say
one party is trying to limit the road
limit the vote
uh but there's other crucial swing
states like florida
you were heavily involved in the
amendment 4 campaign in 2018 to restore
voting rights uh to people who had
served their time in prison to ex-felons
who had done their time and it was a
huge electoral success story 65
of floridians backed it why was it so
important for you john to get behind a
campaign to restore voting rights
uh to felons not the sexiest of issues
but i
believe an important issue for you both
politically and morally
i think it's uh morally um imperative
that we include as many voices as
possible in our democracy
and because someone has committed a
crime
uh does not mean they are not citizens
of this country
and should not have a say in uh
the governance of this country we all
have to pay taxes whether we've
committed a crime or not
we all are participants in this society
we're all affected
by the decisions that our
representatives make and there's no
reason
why there should be a lifetime ban on
people because they committed a crime
and so we fought for that floridians
overwhelmingly
agreed with that and once again
republicans in the state legislature
heard the will of the people and said no
no no we're going to do the opposite
and so what they tried to do was impose
fees and fines
that still made it uh difficult for
millions of people to vote and
we have been fighting that we've raised
money to help people pay off these fees
and fines
but the fact is hundreds of thousands of
people
in florida won't get that right to vote
because
of this uh action by the state
legislature to
uh contradict the will of the people
it is amazing and it should be a much
much bigger story and i'm so glad you're
here with us to talk about it because as
you say you win this amendment you win
this referendum in 2018
overwhelmingly uh huge majority super
majority
you have to win a super majority so uh
that means we had to get 66
of the vote excuse me 60 of the vote and
we got well
uh over 60 of the vote in a state that's
usually very evenly divided
any number of issues and so it was a
clear statement by floridians that
they wanted these folks to be able to
re-enter society and vote
and the state legislature in a very
anti-democratic move
uh decided to rule against the will of
people
in fact they don't not only ruled
against one of the people they say you
have to pay off all your fines and fees
uh which sounds like a poll tax which
has been unconstitutional in this
country
since 1964 asking people to pay all the
fees and fines they owe
not only that but in a kind of orwellian
way i believe they also said we're not
going to tell you
what your fines and fees are and then
when people like yourself or michael
bloomberg come in from outside and say
we're going to try and help people raise
money to pay their fees they attacked
you guys too right
they try to i think matt gates uh
suggested we might be doing something
illegal by uh
uh paying these fees and fines off as if
we were bribing people to vote or
we were paying for their vote uh no uh
they were imposing a poll tax on people
and we
as a charitable effort we're trying to
help people who couldn't afford to pay
these
uh poll taxes and the bottom line is
uh these folks can't even find out how
much they owe just like you said
uh 60 minutes did a great story on it
they they were going through
the uh the files and trying to figure
out what people actually owed and a lot
of people couldn't even determine what
they owed
so they're sitting here uh with this
impossible
uh rule in the way saying they owe this
money but they don't even know what
money they owe
and uh it was a negative
to uh suppress the vote and limit the
vote of people that they expected
may not vote for them
it's worth remembering tomorrow night
we're going to be doing live coverage
here on peacock of the election night
results as they come in
it's worth people remembering if florida
comes down to a few thousand votes again
as it has in the past
as you mentioned well hundreds of
thousands of florians didn't get to vote
in this election even though
amendment 4 was passed by a super
majority it's outrageous
and yet florida governor ron desantis
who led the campaign to block
the implementation of amendment 4 he's
called voting
a privilege when of course it isn't a
privilege it's a right
john is it fair to say that republicans
no longer seem to understand or want to
understand
what democracy is it's not a privilege
they don't believe in democracy they uh
might senator mike lee made a statement
recently uh
calling you know saying democracy was
optional essentially
uh basically if he doesn't like the
results
of what the people vote for then
democracy is optional
and so um i i feel like they're an
entire party that knows they're on the
losing end
of any number of issues when it comes to
uh
women's right to choose when it comes to
whether whether or not
climate change is real when it comes to
whether or not
we have sensible gun regulation
when it comes to gay rights when it
comes to
black lives matter when it comes to any
number of issues the republicans
know that they're on the wrong side of
these issues when it comes to what the
public thinks
when it comes to actually winning the
popular vote they know they've only won
it
once since the year 2000. isn't that
stunning
we've had multiple republican presidents
only one
time since the year 2000 have
republicans actually won the popular
vote
and so now that they don't have an
agenda that people
uh respond to and support now that they
don't have presidential candidates that
people
will vote for they've decided that
democracy
is disposable and that
they only want certain people that they
like to vote
and that's a shame but it's something we
have to fight
every single day and it's really what
this election is about
whether or not we have a real democracy
so you mentioned whether or not we have
a real democracy and you talked about
people who you know they don't want to
vote a lot of that is driven by racism
um i believe it was it one in five
african-american in florida
uh has been disenfranchised due to their
resistance to amendment four and other
such
issues we've seen this year in 2020
two basic stories two big news stories
kovid 19 the coronavirus
and the uprisings the protests against
racism
um the killing of george floyd the
killing of brianna taylor
no accountability in some of those cases
how much do you think race and racism
is going to affect this election is
driving this election john
well i think it's going to be part of
the conversation it has been part of the
conversation
you've even seen donald trump using it
kind of in a backwards way
when he's been obviously racist
throughout his public life whether it
was uh
uh you know not letting black and brown
people live in his apartment buildings
in the 70s
or going after the central park five or
uh being a birther that asked our
president our first black president for
his papers to prove that he was a real
american
who still uh has a muslim ban in place
who called mexicans uh rapists who
come to our country for a better life uh
this guy uh is uh
is trying to use uh racial issues and
criminal justice issues
as a cudgel against joe biden now
admittedly joe biden
helped usher into legislation
the 94 crime bill which i do think was
harmful to so many people
but when it comes to the record on race
the choice is extremely clear biden's
going to win
black and brown boats by an overwhelming
majority
and he's going to win them because we
trust him
to govern in a way that i think will be
more responsive to what we want
and some we expect him to have empathy
and
a heart and really listen to our needs
and our demands
and uh and really govern in a way that's
more responsible
and frankly i mean
yeah when you get to that bar just be
less racist is a low bar to hold for
presidential candidates sadly
um you mentioned joe biden and the crime
bill you
you were an elizabeth warren supporter
in the primaries i know i remember
speaking to you back then
uh now like almost all democrats you're
behind joe biden you want him to win of
course
if he does win as the poll suggests he
might do you think he'll be
progressive enough on the issues you
care most about
getting ex-felons the right to vote
ending mass incarceration
dealing with police violence as you
mentioned yourself he was the author of
the crime bill in the 1990s
a lot of people of color still have
their doubts about him
well first of all i think we all have to
understand what's going on when it comes
to
federal influence on criminal justice
laws versus state and local
the president doesn't have a lot of
power when it comes to
mass incarceration because most
incarceration is in our local jails and
our state
prisons so that's why i spend so much
time
focused on district attorneys that's why
i'm supporting george gascon in los
angeles
and and kim fox in chicago and and
why i supported larry krasner in
philadelphia because
uh so much of our incarceration policy
is driven at the local and state level
that's why
we fight for law changes on the state
and local level as well
so we have to understand that uh the
president does have some influence
they can do computations and pardons
there
are some people in federal prison and
they can change policy
that will affect that sliver of the
incarcerated population that is in the
federal prisons
but yeah the fact is we have to be
vigilant on multiple levels
if we want to end mass incarceration
agree so that we have to be talking to
the president
talking to our national uh legislative
bodies like our senators and our
and our representatives but a lot of the
change that needs to happen is going to
need to happen
on the state and local level and i think
overall we need to understand
that it's our job as citizens
to participate in democracy beyond
voting
that means making it clear to our
leaders what we actually want them to do
once we vote them into office
and so we have to hold joe biden and
kamala harris
accountable when we get them into office
we have to hold them accountable we have
to be paying attention to
the appointments the cabinet
appointments the staffing
decisions that they're making we have to
pay attention to
the priorities when it comes to
legislation
let's pay attention to those things and
not
just simply relax and say we got him
into office and our work is done
one last question john you mentioned
donald trump uh you know birtherizing
the first black president of the united
states you now have uh
carmela harris senator from california
who you're campaigning with tonight in
pennsylvania
uh daughter of a jamaican father indian
mother a child of immigrants woman of
color
as a black man what does that mean to
you to see karma harris
potentially on the verge of becoming a
vice president of the united states
i think it's powerful i think it's
powerful particularly for women
particularly for women of color
particularly for black women south asian
women
i've seen uh the stories that they've
written i've seen
the um the excitement in their faces
knowing that someone that looks like
them could possibly ascend to the second
highest office in the land
uh we i think we a little bit take it
for granted now because
obama was president but still we've
never had a woman
in either uh the president or the vice
president position in this country
this country's been around for centuries
and there's never been a woman
in that in either of those spots and i
think it is meaningful
to have someone be the first
the first woman and the first woman of
color in either of those positions
i think that's a major step for this
country it's not enough
uh having representation having symbols
having
a role model is not enough it's not
policy change
it is not uh it's not the revolution we
need uh when it comes to uh
making serious change in this country
when it comes to misogyny and racism
but it is a step and it's something i
think we should all celebrate
john legend thanks so much